yo yo  wanted to show you guys  this can be a quick video  that's all  i gotta put these rails in that's my job  [Applause]  [Applause]  here we gotta take a rail  and let's look this is a left front rail  okay so we put it in  here like this  slide this guy out  there we go  this is a right front rail  uh yeah yeah we're hiring for  infrastructure  if you want to come to common and work  on infrastructure let me know  all right we gotta slide the rail we  gotta get that  [Applause]  yeah see this one's hard because cause  we don't have a big hole it's only a  small hole  [Music]  yeah there we go  [Music]  right front  [Applause]  and there's the computer that's gonna go  in  [Applause]  thank you for watching it's probably the  70th largest supercomputer in the world  if you go by the list okay there's  probably other secret ones  but  [Music]  um i'll show you a better fan  [Applause]  we have a100s  a100s in our in our small compute  cluster  top 70 supercomputer  [Applause]  you